متابعينا نتابع اذا هذه الصور المباشره
لجثمان اسطوره كره القدم في سانتوس بملعب
فيلا بالميرو قبل حمل النعشي في شوارع
سانتوس الى مقبره قريبه ومن المتوقع اذا
مشاهدينا ان يحضر الرئيس البرازيلي الجديد
لويس اناسيو ل- اا ان يحضر الى هذا المكان
هذا الرئيس الذي ادى اليمين احد الماضي
ربما سيحضر الى ملعب بالميرو قبل وقت قصير
من اخراجه النعشي من الملعب مشاهدينا طبعا
توفي يوم الخميس الماضي عن عمر الناحز
اثنين وثمانين عاما بعد معركه مع السرطان
وهو اللاعب الوحيد الذي فاز بكاس العالم
ثلاثه مرات
شايفين عايزين نعرفهم في متابعه لهذه
الصور المباشره لجثمان اسطوره كره القدم
بليه في سانتوس بملعب فيراب الميرو قبل
حمل النعش في شوارع سانتوس الى مقبره
قريبه وكما ذكرنا يتوقع ان يحضر اذا
الرئيس البرازيلي الجديد لونا دا سيلفا
الذي ادى اليمين الاحد الماضي ان يحضر الى
ملعب الميرو قبل وقت قصير من اخراج النحشي
من الملعب اسره القدم البرازيليه المعروف
مشاهدينا توفي طبعا يوم الخميس الماضي عن
عمر نهز اثنين وثمانين عاما بعد معركه
قاسيه مع مرض السرطان
ويعتبر طبعا هو اللاعب الوحيد الذي فاز
بكاس العالم
لثلاثه مرات
[موسيقى]